promeo peut être professeur de sport
laurine elle est attirée par les métiers
de la santé des orientations déjà bien
établies qui n'ont pas grand chose à
voir avec l'industrie
pourtant la curiosité de ces lycéens les
a poussés à assister à cette visite qui
visitait bon à prendre
plusieurs idées c'est toujours bien donc
visiter plusieurs plusieurs corps de
métier je dirais pas non
là mon père qui travaille ici j'ai pu
découvrir l'endroit où ils travaillent
et ses conditions de forêt cette machine
comme ça évite tout à l'heure on est
déjà en train de l'améliorer immergées
des jeunes dans les ateliers de general
electric a pour but de faire naître des
vocations et de démystifier l'industrie
française qui se tourne de plus en plus
vers le numérique
je pense que c'est plus une journée de
partage où on va leur parler de nos
métiers leur montrer nos produits leur
expliquer la façon dont seront travail
et puis ce qu'on l'a ce qu'on attend de
nos chaînes et de voir aussi le lien
entre les technologies ici et puis les
techniques ces technologies qui vont
être utilisés aussi dans le monde de la
médecine par exemple comme ça a été si
nani laurine romeo ne changeront pas
d'avis sur leur futur métier mais
garderont un bon souvenir de cette
visite
j'ai bien aimé le fait de voir beaucoup
de machines qu'on verra pas tous les
jours de découvrir d'autres sortes de
métiers
la façon dont les gens travaillent c'est
grand c'est très grand il ya beaucoup de
machines de technologie ici je pensais
pas qu'ils avaient tout ça dans une
petite ville comme des forces c'était
peut-être belfortain c'était une fierté
bah ouais du coup un peu plus que la
semaine de l'industrie se termine le 1er
avril
elle a pour thème cette année
l'industrie connectés